hey it's Michelle from love muffin
beauty science the nerdiest beauty nerd
on your screen right now today I'm going
to be discussing how to get vitamin D
without giving yourself too much skin
damage vitamin D is an essential
nutrient for your body and one of the
main sources of vitamin D for humans
it's exposing our skin to UVB radiation
from the Sun but of course UV and sun
exposure also causes skin cancer and
skin aging so we need to be careful
about sun protection we need sunscreen
hats protective clothing and we need to
remember to stay in the shade so what's
the right balance between getting enough
Sun for vitamin D and not having skin
cancer this topic is quite controversial
and there's tons and tons of opinions on
the internet
they aren't many clear guidelines from
medical authorities either so here's my
best attempt at untangling the
information that we have
[Music]
vitamin D is an important vitamin that
has lots of roles in your body it's
famous for maintaining calcium so your
bones don't get soft and you avoid
osteoporosis but it's involved in lots
of other things as well like heart
disease metabolism and preventing cancer
your skin produces vitamin D when it's
exposed to short wavelengths of UV
called UVB it happens with wavelengths
around 270 to 300 nanometers and it
happens the most efficiently at about
295 nanometers the amount of vitamin D
that your body produces when you go out
into the Sun depends on lots of things
like where you live the time of year the
time of day and the color of your skin
as well as making vitamin D in your skin
you can also get vitamin D from your
diet things like fatty fish liver cheese
mushrooms and foods that are specially
modified so that there's vitamin D added
to it
all of these can increase your body's
vitamin D but in general food only
contributes about 10 percent of your
total need of vitamin D you can also
take vitamin D supplements a lot of
people are vitamin D deficient so they
aren't getting enough through the Sun
and food it's something like a quarter
of Australians and 1/3 of people in the
u.s. who are all vitamin D deficient
[Music]
sunscreen blocks a lot of UVB from
entering your skin so it seems logical
to think that wearing sunscreens is
going to lower your vitamin D but a 2009
study found that wearing sunscreen
doesn't actually have too much of an
effect on your vitamin D levels that's
because most people don't apply enough
sunscreen and even if you try to apply
the right amount there are lots of spots
that you miss like your scalp between
your fingers around your eyes and these
spots get enough UV to make vitamin D
there's an interesting idea that you can
make a sunscreen that blocks most UV but
selectively lets in wavelengths of UV
that your skin uses to make vitamin D
the early sunscreen that I know off the
top of my head that does this is called
solar D and it lets in some rays that
are between 290 and 310 nanometers
I personally think this sort of
sunscreen is really going to take off in
the near future
[Music]
it's hard to give an exact figure in
terms of how many minutes of Sun
exposures you should get because of all
those things that I mentioned before
that will affect your vitamin D
production so things like where you live
the time of year the time of day and
what color your skin is
but there are some calculations that
have been done on the minimal
aerothermal dose or meed which is the
minimum amount of UV that makes your
skin go pink there's research that found
that exposing about a quarter of your
body's skin surface to half of the meed
two or three times a week is enough to
get adequate vitamin D synthesis you
also don't need to seem to need Sun all
that regularly for vitamin D your body
can rely on its storages of vitamin D
for a couple of months so you might be
able to get through some of winter
without sunshine different countries
have put out different guidelines for
sun exposure and vitamin D
supplementation so that you can get
enough vitamin D without risking too
much skin damage in the u.s. there
aren't any broad guidelines yet some
scientist suggests that around winter
you should try to get about 15 minutes
of Sun two or three times a week with
your face arms and legs exposed they
recommend that you do this in the middle
of the day when the UVB is highest so
around 11 a.m. till 3 p.m. this
guideline is for people with light
fitzpatrick true skin so if your skin
turns lighter then you need less sun and
if your skin tones darker you're going
to need more I really like the
guidelines given in Australia because
they're really clear and they were put
together in collaboration between people
who think that the Sun is bad
so the Australasian College of
dermatologists and the Cancer Council as
well as the people who think that
vitamin D deficiency is really bad so
the Australian and New Zealand bone a
mineral society The Endocrine Society of
Australia and osteoporosis Australia
these guidelines are also really recent
they were put together in January 2016
so they take into account newer research
on vitamin DS
importance these guidelines say when the
UV index is three or both in the middle
of the day which is most of the year in
Australia Sun Protection is recommended
when you're outdoors for more than a few
minutes so during this time most
Australians will still get enough
vitamin D from incidental exposure even
though they're taking sun protection
measures so even though they're wearing
sunscreen wearing sunglasses wearing
protective clothing wearing hats walking
between the car in the shops going
outside to buy a lunch that sort of
thing will give you enough sunshine to
get vitamin D then in late autumn and
winter when the UV index is below three
sun protection is not recommended and
they say that people should go outdoors
in the middle of the day with some skin
uncovered on most days of the week so
that's really nice and clear and because
it's based on the UV index you can
probably apply that in other places in
the world
just check the UV index for your
location and you can work out what to do
there are some apps that you can use to
do this so for example in Australia
there's the Sun smart app from the
Cancer Council in the UK it's often
cloudy and there's low UVB so in winter
the NHS recommends that almost everyone
should consider taking a vitamin D
supplement I've put links to all this
advice in the caption if you want to
read them in full
[Music]
so in addition to this advice there's a
few things that I want to add that you
should keep in mind sun exposure isn't
just UVB exposure
there's also longer wavelength UVA which
doesn't have any health benefits and
there's also infrared and visible light
that can also cause skin damage UVB is
highest in the middle of the day and
changes quite a lot during the day so
it's quite low in the morning and in the
evening but UVA levels are pretty
constant all throughout the day
sometimes of cost and benefit the middle
of the day seems to be the best time to
get the maximum vitamin D synthesis in
your skin while minimizing skin damage
from other sources
you only really need short exposures to
sunshine to make vitamin D it doesn't
mean that you have to bake in the Sun
for hours your skin slows down how much
vitamin D it makes after a while the
skin damage doesn't really slow down so
you're risking melanoma and other skin
cancers especially if you get sunburned
while you're trying to get vitamin D UVB
doesn't pass through glass so if you're
sitting in a patch of sunshine that's
coming in through a window you're not
going to make much vitamin D however UVA
those longer wavelengths they do pass
through glass which means you'll still
get skin damage tanning beds also
produce way more UVA than UVB so they're
worse than regular sunlight and they've
been definitely linked to skin cancer
if you're using anti-aging ingredients
in your skincare like alpha hydroxy
acids and vitamin A you should still
wear sunscreen since a lot of these can
increase your risk of sun damage if you
can't follow these guidelines or you're
particularly at risk of vitamin D
deficiency like of you or your family
members have had skin cancer if your
skin is really dark or if you're house
bound or if you're just concerned about
your vitamin D levels in general then
you should talk to your doctor about
checking your vitamin D levels and talk
about other options for increasing your
vitamin D so for example perhaps you can
take a supplement in summary small
periods of sun exposure in the middle of
the day will give you vitamin D while
minimizing your chances of skin cancer
and aging sunburn and UVA are still both
really bad and sunscreen is really
unlikely to make you more vitamin D
deficient than you already are
thanks for watching this video if you
liked my video I'd love it if you could
subscribe to my channel you can also
follow me on Facebook and Instagram for
lots and lots of science-based beauty
tips and you can also check out my blog
if you want to read more about beauty
science see you next time for more
nerdery
[Music]